hey 42 here for many years the holy
innocent cemetery in paris
was the largest graveyard in the city
built sometime in the 12th century
it wasn't long before it was simply too
full to accept
individual burials instead opting to
inter its dead in mass graves of 1
500 souls apiece when one of these was
full
they would simply dig another and start
piling up the bodies once more
by the late 1700s after a good 500 years
or so with operation
the holy innocent cemetery was said to
be so full of
half decomposed putrescent bodies buried
not quite far enough beneath the surface
that the air within the graveyard had
the power to
spoil milk and rot meat
even worse the noxious air and saturated
soil
was so oxygen poor that proper
decomposition of the dead
was impossible meaning that instead of
rotting away completely
those buried in the cemetery slowly
turned into gelatinous mounds
of fatty horribleness known as corpse
wax
so many people were buried there that
the cemetery was quite literally
fit to burst and in 1780
it did exactly that when the basement
wall of a neighboring building collapsed
under the sheer weight of
the dead spilling corpses inside
king louis xvi ruler at the time was
forced to take action
ordering that all cemeteries within
paris's city limits
be closed but a problem remained
just what were they going to do with all
the bodies one thing was for sure
they couldn't just leave them there
conditions surrounding the holy innocent
cemetery and others like it
was so bad they formed a kind of
exclusion zone
in which people feared to live and
businesses were unable to operate
so king louis did what any responsible
adult would when faced with an annoying
problem
he put it in an out of the way corner
and did his best
to forget all about it and no corner is
more
out of the way than one buried 20 meters
underground
take that annoying problems over the
course of the next two years
bodies from holy innocent cemetery and
other graveyards across the city
were exhumed and relocated to a series
of caverns
and tunnels beneath the city itself
it's hard to say whether parisians were
happy to have cleared the air
so to speak or were appalled at this
decidedly
unceremonious treatment of their
recently deceased loved ones
although there was one subsection of
society
who greatly approved of this decision
paris's soap boilers and
chandlers were more than happy to
relieve city officials of the tons and
tons
of corpse wax left over after the
exercise
industriously turning it into thousands
of candles and bars of soap
for resale back to the city's residence
because nothing says squeaky clean like
lavaring your ass crack with the
rendered fat of your dead ancestors
incredibly it's fought the ossuary
that's a container or
room used for storing the bones of the
dead you know we all have one of those
lying around
beneath paris is the final resting place
of some six million parisians
meaning there are around three times as
many dead people
in paris as they're all living
to begin with the bones were pretty much
just dumped below the ground in enormous
piles
but in 1810 the city decided to have a
bit of a spring clean
you might be picturing neat stacks of
coffin-like boxes to house the bones
but parisians have always had a flair
for design instead of simply
tidying them away city officials used
the bones themselves
as decoration building undulating walls
out of grinning skulls
and stacked femoral heads it should be
horrifying but
i don't know it does kind of work maybe
i'll get one for the studio
today the ossuary is a tourist
attraction with thousands of people
paying their entry fee to go and look at
the pretty dead people
unsurprisingly considering how many
bones are housed there
the ossuary is big spanning some 1.5
kilometers of tunnels
pretty impressive i'm sure you'll agree
but
believe it or not this makes up only a
tiny
portion of the true extent of caverns
and tunnels
that lie hidden beneath paris's famous
cafe line streets
and plush luxury fashion boutiques
you see the tunnels king louie used to
house the bones of paris is dead
were not dug expressly for that purpose
they were already there one small part
of a far
larger complex of mines that
crisscrossed the city's earthy
underbelly
to this day and you can be one small
part of a far larger community
of entrepreneurs with today's sponsor
trends
if you're a budding entrepreneur
investor or just have
ambitions for personal growth trends is
an
absolute gold mine let me tell you
in business timing and insider knowledge
are everything when you subscribe to
trends you get access to a community of
industry leaders in virtually every
field
where you can learn how to capitalize on
emerging opportunities
want to identify soon to be highly
profitable markets
so you can launch now and pipple your
potential competitors
to the money tree well trend provides
regular signals
that tell you exactly what those
emerging markets are
and it's the only place i've found to
get that information it's like having a
time machine
the business experts and industry
leaders at trends
also publish regular articles i
particularly enjoyed the trends article
27 margins lessons from the paper
notebook business
which taught me how a notebook company
like moleskin
can be more profitable than coca-cola
i'm amazed at the wealth of information
here
i'm sure some of this stuff should be
labeled as classified
trends is also a place to network with
other entrepreneurs and investors
and there are weekly live lectures from
experts
who teach growth strategies seo
and much more right now you can get your
first two weeks
for just one dollar go to trends dot
co 42 for your
one dollar two-week trial don't miss
this one guys
many cities around the world look the
way they do
because of the building materials found
nearby
houses in bath in the uk are largely
made from bath stone
a honey-colored limestone that gives
baths buildings
their unique look and many of the
buildings in nerd lingan
germany are made from stone packed with
millions of tiny diamonds
the town was built in a 15 million year
old crater
and the meteorite which made it happens
to impact a large graphite's deposit
creating an estimated 000 tons
of micro diamonds embedded in the
surrounding stone
which was later quarried and used for
building
you can imagine the local estate agents
having a field day with that one
paris was built in much the same way and
many of its buildings including
iconic landmarks like the louvre and the
intricate facade of notre dame cathedral
sadly ravaged by fire in 2019 are built
largely from
lutetian limestone which has been mined
in the region since the late 13th
century
and what does half a millennium or so of
mining get to you
well aside from enough stone to build a
grand city like paris
you're left with an awful lot of holes
in the ground though it's hard to gauge
accurately
there are thought to be some 350
kilometers of tunnels
hidden just below the surface of the
french capital like
some impossibly complex subterranean
maze
known today as the catacombs of paris
these tunnels are so extensive that when
filibert
aspart doorkeeper of the valdergrass
hospital in paris during the french
revolution
entered them in november of 1793
he never found his way back out again
why he went down there isn't known nor
is what exactly happened to him beneath
the ground
perhaps he got lost and succumbed to
dehydration
maybe he just got unlucky and died of
natural causes
either way it took 11 years until his
body was discovered
by which time he was only identifiable
by the hospital keys he'd carried in
life
aspart was buried where he was found i
mean it is awfully convenient when
people are considerate enough to die
inside a mass grave
and he remains there to this day
in 2017 two teenagers got lost in the
catacombs
for a full three days and were only
tracked down thanks to specialized
search and rescue dogs
the kids got lucky escaping only with
mild cases of hypothermia
but if the alarm hadn't been raised
they may well have perished lost in the
labyrinth
the mines are thought to cover some 32
square kilometers beneath the city
that's about 10 times the size of
central park in new york
the area of paris above ground is 105
square kilometers
meaning the catacombs cover almost one
third of the total area like a whole
second city
hidden underground but as you can
probably imagine
having all this empty space beneath a
huge and bustling urban metropolis
doesn't make for the sturdiest of
foundations which
begs the question why undermine your own
city
both literally and figuratively in the
first place
as you might have guessed they didn't
when these mines were created paris
wasn't the global city it is today
and its inhabitants numbered just three
hundred thousand
at the time the mines were a perfectly
sensible and safe distance from the city
but once they were exhausted they were
abandoned
but as the old saying goes out of sight
out of mind as generations went by
the existence of the minds was forgotten
by just about
everyone and over the years paris grew
in all directions
for the most part nobody knew the city's
new houses
offices and monuments were being built
on the shakiest of foundations that is
until 1774
when around 30 meters of the rueda
amphur disappeared
into a gaping cavern 30 meters deep
this collapse and others like it led to
the formation
of the inspection general de carriere
known as the igc which was founded by
royal decree of king louis xvi
in 1777 to investigate
and maintain the mines that's just three
years before he would use them to solve
his little
oh [ __ ] the streets are full of corpses
problem by the way
despite the work of the igc which is
still going strong today
they complete hundreds of surveys and
interventions each year
to ensure the safety of the city above
ground
collapses still occur in 1961
22 people were killed when a whole
neighborhood disappeared overnight
in one of paris's suburbs so remember
the next time you find yourself woken by
a rumbling from below
as you lay awake at night in your quaint
parisian hotel
it might not be the result of those
undercooked escargot you gorged on its
dinner
you may be about to find yourself taking
a ride
on the world's fastest elevator all the
way down to the ground floor
and beyond interestingly enough
according to parisian law
when you buy a house in paris you aren't
just buying the house itself
you're also taking ownership of the
ground beneath it
that means if your property starts to
subside
it's you that has to foot the bill for
fixing it something to think about
before signing on the dotted line for
your swanky parisian townhouse
in the years since their creation the
paris catacombs have served
many different purposes for much of the
20th century
farmers used the empty quarries to
cultivate mushrooms
known as champagne de paris growing over
one
000 tonnes of them each year at peak
production
members of the french resistance used
the tunnels for their covert operations
during the second world war as did the
nazis they were attempting to thwart
the germans built a large bunker in an
abandoned mine below laissez montagna
one of paris's most famous schools whose
alumni includes
carl lagerfeld and several prime
ministers the catacombs also served as
the location of a publicity
stunt for airbnb when they offered
two lucky guests the chance to spend the
night in what they described as
the world's largest grave it was
reported at the time that airbnb paid
the city
350 000 euro for the privilege
today only the ossuary portion of the
catacombs
accessible via guided tour is open to
the public
the rest of the 350 kilometers of
sprawling
labyrinth is strictly off limits it's
been illegal for the general public to
enter
since 1955. that's partly because
they're dangerous
partly because damaging them might cause
half the city to fall down
and partly because as i mentioned
parisian law states that the ground
beneath
a home belongs to its owner by entering
the catacombs
you are quite literally trespassing
on other people's property but a vast
underground city brimming with secret
passageways and unexplored caves
has over the years proven irresistible
to paris's more adventurous citizens
like a real life london below from neil
gaiman's novel
neverwhere only in paris obviously
the catacombs represent a whole other
city
hidden away just below the surface
unknown to most who walk in the daylight
above
caterphiles that's the name given to the
people who venture into the catacombs
have been busy exploring it for decades
many are artists drawn by what is an
enormous blank
canvas where freedom of expression is
king
and the normal rules don't apply others
are simple explorers attracted by the
irresistible pull of the unknown
and the chance to map the endless
uncharted tunnels
and galleries some are in it simply for
fun
secret parties concerts art festivals
and raves are common occurrences in the
catacombs
attracting the kind of ultra-hip crowd
that paris does better than anywhere
else
some chambers are said to be big enough
to hold over a thousand
partygoers at a time getting into the
catacombs however
is not straightforward police and
private homeowners
have been blocking off known entry
points for years
with the location of many of those that
remain hidden in metro tunnels
sewers and under bridges and known only
to a select few
you might assume being a cataphile was a
young man's game
but it isn't only hipsters and
adventurers who spend their nights
beneath the city
billionaire xavier neal the 21st richest
man in france
according to forbes claims to head down
there twice a week
via a secret staircase he had specially
installed
in his basement he's been a regular in
the catacombs since his younger days
when he first struck gold investing in
the online sex
chat industry reminds me of my own youth
only i didn't make any money as you
might expect
below ground there is also something of
a criminal
underworld at work in the catacombs in
in a heist worthy of oceans 15
16 an enterprising group of thieves
stole 250
000 euro worth of vintage wine
after boring into the wine cellar of an
extensive home
directly from the catacombs the
operation was meticulously planned
and perfectly executed with the precious
bottles spirited away
through the winding tunnels and never
seen again
the secret society known only as le ux
are perhaps the most famous frequencies
of the catacombs
the group came into being when six
parisian teenagers pulled off a stunt
worthy of fred and george weasley
using the catacombs to infiltrate the
ministry of telecommunications
and coming away with the jackpot
the city schematics of the entire tunnel
network
leg ux had found their very own
marauders map
and they've been using it to manage
mischief in the catacombs
ever since it was a subsection of lay ux
known as the mexican consolidated
drilling authority
yeah i don't get the names either who
took credit
for a bizarre discovery made there by
parisian police
during a training exercise in the
catacombs in 2004
hidden beneath the city in a dusty and
rarely explored corner of the tunnel
network
was an entire cinema described as
resembling an underground amphitheater
complete with full-sized screen high
quality projector and
chairs cut right out of the rock a
neighboring cave had even been turned
into a restaurant and
bar stocked with bottles of spirits and
a pressure cooker
somehow the group had managed to connect
the cinema
to the electrical grid and they'd even
installed phone lines down there
the whole thing was guarded by a motion
detecting cctv setup
which was designed to trigger the sound
of dogs barking
whenever someone approached presumably
to scare away any catophiles
who stumbled on it by accident according
to sources from the group
the cinema had been in use for many
years by the time it was discovered
when the police returned to the site
three days later to take the cinema down
they found the space had already been
gutted with all the equipment removed
and electricity and phone lines cut
la ux had been kind enough to leave a
note for the police though
it simply read don't try to find us
not creepy at all if caterpiles are to
be believed there are dozens of these
kinds of
hidden away spaces beneath the city most
of which will only ever be found by
those who are brave enough to go looking
for them
which i hasten to add most certainly
won't be me
thanks for watching thanks again to
trends for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check them out using the
link in the description